RON LIEBER: Hi, y'all.
Thanks so much for coming.
I want to start by telling
you a little bit about how
that boy with that hair became
this guy with a little bit
less hair, and became somebody
who was obsessed with money
for a living, but also obsessed
with talking to kids about it.
And it happened because
of something that happened
to me and to our family.
That's my brother
David right there.
He's a Googler who keeps
the world safe for you
guys in Washington, DC.
With all the people who
are trying to regulate,
you have to do that.
So you have him to thank
for-- wait, what was it?
Permission list innovation.
Yeah, David keeps the world safe
for permission list innovation.
So anyway, that's
me at 10 or 11.
When I was about 12, when
David was about seven
and his twin sister was
seven, our parents split up.
If any of you guys have
been through a divorce,
you know that it can
change things financially.
It can change things
emotionally, too.
But financially, what happens
is that one household turns
into two.
That itself often causes a
decline in general standard
of living, because
the two houses usually
are not separately as
nice as the one house was.
So it starts there.
At the same time, one of
our parents lost their job.
And it was another
10 or 15 years
until our family got back to
where we had been economically
before.
So we were lucky
in some respects.
We went to a really terrific
private school in Chicago
the community rallied around.
All of us Lieber kids
went on financial aid.
It was completely seamless.
But four years later, I
was ready to go to college.
I was ready to
apply for college.
I knew I would
need financial aid.
I didn't know very much
about how the system worked.
Neither did my mother.
But what happened
right at that moment
when I was a senior
in high school
was that my mother,
somebody slipper her--
we still don't even
know who it was--
somebody slipped her the phone
number of a guy who could help.
And it turned out,
this guy-- and his name
has been lost to
history, although I
am this close to tracking
it down as we speak,
because I need tell him
that I've been out talking
about him-- this guy
was an Assistant Dean
of Financial Aid at Northwestern
University, about 10 miles
north of where we lived.
And what we were told was that
this guy knew all the tricks
to the financial aid system.
So we went to see this guy.
He takes us into his
office at Northwestern.
It's 5:01 PM on a weekday.
All of his colleagues
are gone so that they
don't know what he's doing.
He closes the door.
He locks it behind them.
We put $100 on his
desk, and he proceeds
to explain to us all of the
secrets of the financial aid
system.
He wasn't encouraging
us to break the law.
He was just explaining--
this number goes here,
and this number goes
here, and if you really
want to make yourself look
as attractive as possible
to the equations that the
financial aid deans are using--
this was
pre-algorithms-- he said
you put your numbers
in this place,
and maybe you move your
money from this account
to that account.
And it's all perfectly
legal, but it will help you.
And it did.
I got into college.
I got a really generous
package of financial aid.
I got out of school with under
$10,000 in student loan debt.
It made a huge difference.
And I learned a couple
of things from that
that turned out to be really
important to me later in life.
First of all, I
learned that the world
is filled with complex
systems involving money,
and that they are made
to be hacked, legally.
And the second part
was the mere fact
that my mother had even
taken me along for that ride
in the first place, because
she didn't have to, right?
She could have just
put the financial aid
forms in front of me and
told to sign on line 127,
and I would have had
to read the rest of it,
and she could have shielded
me from all of that.
But she didn't.
She knew that this was
going to affect my life even
more than it impacted hers.
And she saw no reason
to hide from me.
She had no shame about the fact
that we didn't have enough.
She was, in fact, proud that
she was ingenious enough
to get the number for the guy.
So I went along for the ride.
I had a front row seat for
all of these machinations.
Each and every year, in
fact, we met with the dean
at Amherst College, where I
intended to ask for more money.
I was a part of the process.
And so there is
no reason, really,
to shield kids from this stuff.
It impacted my life.
It was important.
I didn't think all that
much about that incident,
that chapter of my
life, until much later.
It was 2002.
The Wall Street Journal was
starting their personal journal
section, the Consumer News
section that they still
run to this day.
I got hired to work
for that section,
to write for that section.
And what the editors there,
in the tradition of the very
best editors, what they did,
what they saw in me that I had
not seen in myself was they
said, Ron, your beat in life
and your beat in the newspaper
ought to be beating the system.
And it all clicked for me.
It was like windows opening up
in my brain all of a sudden.
Because I remembered
what we had done
with financial aid,
and the fact that I
had spent all the
1990s exploiting
every last loophole of the
frequent flyer miles system--
that that was the person I was.
It was the person I had become.
It was the life's call
and the work calling
that I was growing into.
So I became the
person at the journal
who wrote the story about how
to return all of your wedding
gifts for cash,
which it turns out
is something that you can
do at certain select stores.
And this information
had been traded
on the wedding underground,
but most people didn't know.
And so I made sure
everybody knew it.
Some of you may be aware that
yet another Yahoo is trying
to start helicopter service
from the heliport to JFK,
as if that's something
that makes sense to do.
Well, it turns out,
the last time somebody
tried to do this was right after
we started the Personal Journal
section.
And I had a hunch
that taking the subway
would actually be faster
than taking the helicopter,
so we tested it.
The subway beat the
helicopter by seven minutes.
So how is that possible?
This is the question
my editor asked
before I asked him
for $250 so I could
take the helicopter myself.
I said, what people
don't realize
is that you have to cross
town to get to the heliport.
That could take 40
minutes at rush hour.
And then you have
to wait for TSA,
and then you have to
get on the helicopter,
get off the helicopter.
And what the helicopter
people do not tell
you is that there's only one
drop off for the helicopter.
The helicopter doesn't
take off and land
at each successive terminal.
They just dump you
at terminal seven,
and if your flight
is in terminal three,
you'll be walking for
23 minutes to get there.
So the subway beat
the helicopter,
and I became that person.
And the journal realized
relatively quickly
after that that what I was doing
was actually personal finance.
They had defined
personal finance earlier
than that as just investing.
And they were very
good at writing
about investing, very good
at writing about the markets.
But all this other stuff,
all of these different ways
that money hits you in the
wallet, that money hits you
in the brain, the connections
between money and emotions,
and all the decisions that
we have to make-- this
was something else
entirely, and we
realize that we should
write about it more.
Within a couple years,
"The New York Times"
noticed what I was doing.
They hired me as their
personal finance columnist.
I thought I was on
top of the world.
I knew it all.
And then I had a child.
And there is nothing that
shakes up your worldview
or your self confidence
by being solely or duly
responsible for somebody else.
And very quickly, within
just a couple of years,
our daughter was asking us
a lot of really complicated,
cosmic questions about money.
And I was tongue tied.
I was tongue tied because
these money questions involve
a lot of deep seated emotions,
and feeling, and shame,
and yearning, and envy, and
confusion about where we stand
and how we stack up.
They were parenting
questions, too.
This kid, my flesh and blood--
I wanted to imprint her
with all of my best values
and none of my bad habits--
was asking me these
intense questions.
I wanted to get
the answer right.
And even though I played
Dr. Money in the newspaper
on the weekends, I did not
know what to say to her.
So I did what I
normally do now when
I don't know the answer
to a question-- I
asked the internet.
And on a blog on
newyorktimes.com,
I started posting some
of these questions
that I was hearing
about from kids.
And I posted some answers,
some rough drafts.
A bunch of commenters poured in.
We would revise the answers.
We had some pretty
good scripts going.
But then right around the
time of Occupy Wall Street,
I heard from a couple of
parents in the community,
greater New York City.
They said to me, Ron,
we've got a problem here.
In our community, the people
with more-- people with more
money than average, more
stuff, with bigger homes--
they're starting
to feel demonized.
Some people at the
school and other parents
are starting to make comments
that the kids shouldn't take
taxis to school, that
they should stop talking
about their vacations when
they're on school property,
that they should leave
their cell phones at home,
that the birthday party
should be less lavish.
And those parents felt like
they were having to apologize,
not just for what they had,
but ultimately, who they were.
And that didn't feel very good.
And the people with less,
they were just as upset.
They felt like their noses
were being rubbed deliberately
in other people's affluence
at a time when a lot of people
were really hurting.
And the schools were
totally useless.
Because to the extent that
they had diversity curriculums
at all, they were talking
almost entirely about race
and saying absolutely
nothing about social class.
And it's a tough conversation
to have in New York City,
particularly in
a private school.
But even in some of
the private publics
where you need to
afford a $1 million
apartment or a
$5,000 monthly rent
to get into the school
district in the first place.
Because if you're having
that conversation,
then you are acknowledging
that 40%, 50%, 60%,
80% of the people in the
school are in the 1% or the 2%.
And then you are
elite if not elitist.
And that's a difficult thing
to reckon with, to really check
your privilege in that way.
So those conversations weren't
going on at the schools.
Parents were talking about it
in huddles on the sidelines.
They saw what I was
writing in the newspaper,
and they said, Ron, you
should come in and speak
to our entire parent
body and set everybody
straight on this stuff.
So I only hesitated
for one single second
before saying yes.
And it wasn't because
I knew the answer,
but it was because I knew
this was a fundamentally
new question in
personal finance,
and I'm always
looking for those.
Because the basics we've more or
less solved for at this point.
You know you're supposed to
spend less than you make,
and get your estate in order,
get all those documents ready,
have enough insurance,
put a bunch of money away
for retirement-- maybe in index
funds, maybe in Google stock
if you have no
choice in the matter,
and you're not allowed to
sell, you're locked up right.
So this is what we do.
But this question,
this whole question
of how to deal with kids
and their pressing questions
about money, and
social class, and who
has more, and who has less,
and how that came to pass,
and whether it's fair--
this felt new to me.
So I tried to figure out
what all of these parents
had in common.
And I asked myself a question.
I said, all right,
well, if it was you,
and you were trying to think
of the single worst word
that somebody
might theoretically
use to describe your child, a
word that would be the biggest
indictment of your own, my own
parenting, what would it be?
And the first thing that
popped in my head was spoiled.
And it wasn't so much because
it's the worst thing on Earth.
I wouldn't want somebody
describing my child as mean.
I wouldn't want
someone to describe
my child as racist or cruel.
But spoiled, it made the
hair rise on my arms,
because I knew it really
was an indictment of me
if somebody were
ever to use that.
Because spoiled
is a passive verb.
It's not just an adjective.
Spoiled by whom?
Spoiled by you, by
us, by the parents.
Because kids aren't
born that way.
Spoiled kids are generally made.
So I thought, OK, if that's
what we're trying to solve,
for then what's the
opposite of spoiled?
And that wasn't useful at
first, because if you look it up
in the thesaurus,
you get fresh, which
is useful for produce
and meat and stuff,
but not for children.
So I tried to make a
list of all of the values
and virtues and character
traits that add up
to the kinds of
grounded, decent kids
that we're all
trying to push out
into the world-- things
like modesty, and thrift,
and prudence, and patience,
and delayed gratification,
and perseverance, and grit,
and perspective, and curiosity.
Generosity is a big one.
And I looked at that list.
And I thought, whoa,
you can use money
to teach every single
one of those things.
So rather than assume, as
some of those schools are,
that money subverts
values, that talking
about it leads to the creation
of money grubbing children,
or that their
questions about money
were impolite or impolitic
or age inappropriate--
what if we did the inverse?
What if we actually
embraced those questions,
we answer them transparently,
but in an age appropriate way?
What if we used those
questions to lead us
on years-long conversations
and even family rituals
around saving and
spending and giving,
all in the interest of
imprinting all that good stuff?
What if we did that instead?
And so what the
opposite of spoiled is,
first and foremost, is a
solemn promise to our children.
It's a generational
manifesto, really,
that says more
than anything else
that we are going to do
better at this money stuff
than our parents did.
We're going to
talk about it more.
We're going to take our
kids questions seriously,
and we are going to answer
every single one of them.
And it makes perfect sense.
Because more than anything else,
it's kids' job to be curious.
They're supposed to figure
out how the world works.
Money is clearly
a source of power,
but it's also a
source of mystery.
Grownups don't talk
about it very much.
Kids need some math skills, at
least 10-year-old math skills,
to really reckon
with the numbers.
So they're trying
to sort it out,
and they're getting
little snippets of it.
And if we're trying
to hide it from them--
or even worse, if
we're lying-- that's
not going to be good for
a variety of reasons.
And so if you're like me, you
probably heard some version
of this answer to at least
one of your money questions
when you're growing up.
So you're asking, how
much does the house cost,
or how much money do
you make, or what to you
pay our babysitter, and the
answer is, almost inevitably--
at least at some point in
many people's childhood-- it's
none of your business.
So this is a problematic answer
for a whole bunch of reasons.
First of all, it's not true.
It's literally
factually inaccurate.
Because if you are a member
of the household, a member
of the family
business, in a sense,
its revenues and expenses
of course impact you.
So it's stuff that
affects your daily life,
and of course you're
going to ask about it.
But even worse, if you
shut down kids in that way,
if you tell them that it's
not of their business,
the lesson that they get is
this matter of great import
is utterly and
completely off limits.
And so if they want to know
about this really important
thing, then the
best place to go is
Google, or their friends on the
playground, or someplace else,
even though we as
parents almost certainly
want to be the primary resource
for really important stuff.
And if it happens with money,
they may come to the conclusion
that they shouldn't
ask you about sex,
and they shouldn't
ask you about drugs,
ask you about help.
Because this is important
stuff, it's consequential stuff,
it's scary stuff.
And if you're shutting
them down on money, well,
you might shut them down
on those things, too,
and so they'll just keep
their curiosity to themselves.
So if anything else,
please wipe the phrase none
of your business from your
vocabulary if you possibly can.
If you're looking for a
better answer, an all purpose
answer that works for every
single money question,
I'd suggest this.
Your kid wants to know
how much you make,
or whether you're rich,
or whether you're poor,
or why you didn't give
money to the homeless person
on the street.
Just look back at them and
say, oh, why do you ask?
And it's not an accusation.
It's meant to convey the fact
that we honor their curiosity,
that we appreciate it, that
we are glad that they asked,
but that we want to
know what made them
think of it in the first place.
Particularly the younger ones,
the bigger cosmic questions--
are we rich, are we poor.
Those aren't usually what
they're looking to answer.
So if they're asking you
how much money you make,
but you know that they don't
have the math skills to reckon
with a six figure number
or a seven figure number
if they're talking
about real estate
that you own in Manhattan,
then often, they're
asking about something else.
And often, it's a
question that is
something to do with a
generalized query about
whether they are OK.
They're asking about rich or
they're asking about poor,
because they've overheard an
argument that two parents are
having, or they've
overheard a single parent
on the phone with a creditor,
a financial advisor.
Once they can read,
all bets are off.
They're looking at
newspaper headlines.
They're looking at your bills.
They worry.
They see stuff.
They snoop.
Did you go after the tax
returns in the basement?
That was just me?
That was just me.
I got my hands on the tax
returns when I was 13 or 14.
Just because I saw them
there, and I thought,
that would be
useful information.
But I had no way to
contextualize that.
So they're going to look.
They're going to ask.
And this is a pretty good
all purpose response--
why do you ask?
Because quite often,
they've overheard something
or, they've seen something
that's made them curious.
And quite often, what
they really want to know
is about that, and not
what your net worth is.
And it turns out that the
why do you ask response
is useful in other ways, too.
So when I talk about this,
I think of my friend Kristi.
Lives in the West Village,
but grew up elsewhere.
Her father is a nice
Southern gentleman.
Comes to visit
sometimes, although he
thinks that New York is
the root of all evil.
So they're sitting in
the living room one day,
and Kristi's son walks in, pulls
himself up to his full height,
he addresses them,
and he says, when
are we going to start having
some more sex around here?
So as far as I know,
Kristie had never really
had the sex conversation
with her own father.
She certainly hadn't
had it with her son
yet, because he was like seven.
And so she had to figure out
in the moment what to say,
and she didn't have the
why do you ask trick up
her sleeve at that point.
So she delivers an abbreviated
version of the birds
and the bees with her
father as an audience.
And days later,
only days later does
she realize what was actually
going on in that moment.
She finally got to
the bottom of it.
It turns out Gus had
stolen a couple of minutes
in front of a
Family Guy episode,
and what he realized was
that if you say the word
sex enough times, the
laugh track explodes.
So it wasn't that
Gus wanted to have
sex with his mother, or
his grandfather, or anyone.
He just wanted to create
some entertainment.
And if only she
had asked why, she
could have gotten to the
bottom of it in that moment
without having the sex
talk with a seven-year-old.
So why do you ask-- it's a
really great tool to have.
So we know that kids
should learn about money.
Money is for practice.
It is a great teaching tool.
I see it as being in the
same category as books,
as musical instruments,
as art supplies.
I know we grownups
connect it with commerce,
but I really think
it's for learning.
If you give kids allowance, it's
good to ask them to divide it
in three in this way.
You can split it up
really any way you want.
But the thing that I like about
this is that, first of all,
it offers a basic foundation
for grown up budgeting, not
that far off from what we do.
If you're relatively
healthy financially,
you're spending maybe no
more than 75% or 80% of what
you make.
Hopefully you're
saving 10%, 15%,
maybe more if you're looking at
college education down the pike
and you can afford to.
And you're giving
away what you can.
Maybe there's some giving
pledgers in the audience.
I won't ask you to
call yourself out.
But some folks with
significant net worths
have decided to pledge,
literally on a dotted line,
to give away 50% of their net
worth over their lifetime.
Maybe you're a Mormon
and you tithe 10%.
If you're like most
Americans, you give away 2.5%
roughly on average each year.
But hopefully, you're
able to give something.
But this is a beginning
grown up budget for kids.
But I also like the
fact that the jars
are a stand in for those values
and virtues and character
traits that we were
talking about before.
So spend is modesty, it's
thrift, it's prudence
and prudent financial
decision making.
But it's not necessarily
about being cheap.
I'm actually a big believer
in spending lavishly on things
that bring you the most joy.
So for me, it's live music.
I'm a big customer of StubHub.
I'm willing to
pay more if I need
to for a better
experience, because I
know it will be memorable.
Same thing is true
for food for me.
That's something else
that's really important.
But then there are
other things-- clothing,
alcohol, transportation-- I
don't spend on that stuff.
And you probably
have your own list.
And you should help
your kids figure out
what's on their list, the things
the bring them the most joy.
It turns out all of
the best happiness
research shows us
now-- I mean literally,
definitively now, every study
shows this-- that doing things
trumps having things,
that experiences
are better than stuff.
The earliest that we can start
teaching our kids about that,
the better.
So that's spend.
Save is about patience
and delayed gratification,
which helps grownups when
they're saving for retirement
or college or something
else, especially
in a world that now
conspires against waiting
in so many ways.
All of you guys are
old enough to remember
going to Blockbuster and not
being able to get the movie.
That's just not part of
anybody's life anymore.
Neither are television
commercials,
unless it's a live sports
event or the Oscars.
It's just not something
we have to do.
Many kids don't have to share a
bathroom in the suburbs at all.
Things have changed.
And giving is about generosity,
and also about gravity.
So I often get a lot of
questions about chores.
I think kids should
do a ton of chores,
so many that you need a
chore chart like the ones
that I found in Mormon
households filled
with children all over Utah.
This is one that I saw.
I went there
deliberately to see what
life was like in houses
that have four or five
or 8 or 12 children around just
to see at its most intense what
the chore charts are like.
I actually think that kids
should do chores for free,
the same way that grownups do.
If you're looking for
leverage over your kids
and you're tempted to take away
their allowance if they don't
do their chores,
consider the possibility
that they may value some
of their experiences, some
of the things that they love
to do, way more than they
value the money.
You could take away
their screen time.
the Wi-Fi password.
You could take
away their ability
to go to soccer practice.
There's a lot of things you
can take that are probably more
valuable to them than money.
So this is what a
chore chart looks
like at its most extreme--
color-coded goals,
homemade bottle cap magnets,
tracking all the things that
need to be done each day.
The kids get points according
to how engaged they are.
There's a weekly schedule
that changes on a daily basis.
And the chores are
incredibly intense.
I still don't know
what an entry bench is.
I definitely don't have one
in my Brooklyn apartment.
But out in Utah, they've got
to be dusted every single day.
The mud rooms get washed,
the doors, both sides,
the light switches.
This family was so
intense that they
had decided at a certain point
that the activity in front
of the sink in the kitchen
had just become too extreme,
and so they installed an
industrial water fountain right
next to the mud room so that all
of the water container filling
in the kids' drinking could
be moved someplace out
of the kitchen.
This family had a lot going
on, and they had figured
out a system for all of it.
And all those chores got done.
Another thing about allowance
that's useful for kids--
and really, it's a useful way
of thinking for grownups, too.
It's changed the way I
think about spending.
It's starting to talk to
them about the difference
between wants and needs.
So I use rubber rain boot,
Wellies, to illustrate this.
But you could really do
it with sports equipment,
or athletic shoes, or
underwear or outerwear,
anything you want.
And in fact, I encourage you
to do with every category
of spending in your household.
But this is how we do
it with rain boots.
So is anybody wearing
hunter boots today?
So nobody is going
to be annoyed at me.
I actually don't have a
problem with luxury products
in general.
But these Hunter boots on
teenage girls and younger,
it kept coming up again and
again in my reporting that
became a thing in my
head-- luxury rain boots,
generally girls wearing them,
although sometimes boys.
They cost $70 or $80 or $90
or $100 for the kids version.
It's a lot.
But still-- kids
need rain boots.
You can get the $20
version at Payless
or buy them used on eBay.
You can get the
really expensive boot
over on the right side of
the want need continuum.
I encourage parents to
draw a vertical line
in between the crosses of the
continuum that basically says
to kids, this is what
we are willing to pay
for in this category.
My family often draws what
we call the Lands' End Line.
Because I grew up
in the Midwest,
I'm a big consumer of Land's
End, a long time customer.
I think their products are
high quality, great customer
service, nice return policy.
You get to talk to those ladies
in Wisconsin on the phone.
Those ladies are so nice.
So what we say to
our daughter is,
we'll pay for the Lands'
End version of this.
With the rain boots,
it's $40, $45.
If you want something more
expensive, it's on you.
So you're going to pay the
difference between $40 and $45
and whatever it
is that you want.
And you can draw that
line anywhere you want.
No judgments.
Your family may be a $4
a pair underwear family.
Because really, why do
you need underwear that's
more expensive than that?
But it may be a
$200, $300 outer wear
family, because you go skiing,
or because your kids walk
to school in the elements.
And so the coat is
important, and you're
willing to spend more for that.
Whatever it is, the
only wrong answer
is the one that you don't
explain to your kids.
Because otherwise,
how else are they
supposed to know why and how
you're making the decisions
that you're making?
So I mentioned to you that
this came up again and again.
One of the very first talks
I gave on this topic, a mom
in the front row raised
her hand and said
to me, my son stumped me
recently, my 10-year-old son.
He wanted to know
why it was that we
kept refusing to buy
him a carnivorous plant
terrarium given that
we were willing to pay
for his 12-year-old
sister's Hunter boots.
And the room broke up laughing.
And I thought about
it for half second.
And then I realized that
that 10-year-old boy
had seized on something that
the mother didn't really
understand at all, which
was that these things are
two different categories, two
different want need continuums.
What he was talking about, his
carnivorous plant terrarium,
what he was talking about
was a tool for learning.
So if your family
is lucky enough
to have enough money that
you pay for most tools
for learning-- most books,
most instruments, most
educational toys--
then you should
pay for the carnivorous
plant terrarium,
because that's botany, and
plant science, and hydrology,
and insects.
And he wanted to take
care of the stuff
and learn things from it,
and that's good stuff.
But his sister, his sister
just wanted a luxury product.
It was definitely
a need, way far
off the need end
of the spectrum,
and not a want at all.
So I said to her, the
answer here is simple.
You should definitely buy the
Venus fly traps for the kids.
But we made an agreement
that after a certain point,
he should have to pay
for all the flies.
And that was the deal she cut.
So I put this all
down in my book.
I thought I had it
all figured out.
And then I was at my alma
mater, our alma mater,
a couple of weeks ago
talking about Hunter boots
and all of the
rest of this stuff.
And I got home a
couple hours later.
There was a Facebook
thread going
among my classmates, who had
all come out to hear me speak.
And my poor classmate
Collin had do
admit, or decided to
admit to the rest of us,
that on the way
home from the talk,
his wife had pulled those
out of a shopping back.
Literally that day,
she had gone out
and bought their
two-year-old Hunter boots.
So I thought I was
in big trouble.
And then Colin thought
he was in big trouble.
People were asking about it.
And he said, no, no,
you don't understand.
He said, my wife got
the boots on sale,
so they were to the left
of the Lands' End Line.
So they win.
Buying on sale is a
really good thing.
So we were looking at
the gift jar before.
Kids turn out to be
hard-wired for generosity.
This is a drawing that was made
by a six-year-old in Queens who
had a lot of questions
about Occupy Wall Street.
She had asked her
parents what it meant.
She couldn't really
read the signs
or understand what
they were about.
Her parents did a really good
job of explaining it to her.
They said, well,
there are people
in New York City who have a lot
of money and a lot of property,
and they're really
lucky that they do.
And there are people in
New York City who have
a lot less and who struggle.
And what the signs are
about is a conversation
that we're having in
New York right now about
whether that's fair, that
many people have more
and many people have less.
And if it isn't fair, what
should we do to fix it?
So she took all that in.
She sat down at her art table,
and she drew a share machine.
So the way the
share machine works
is you dump a bunch of
gold into the pink funnel,
and the gold goes
into the machine,
and it regurgitates the gold
into red coins and blue coins,
and those red and blue
coins get mixed up
in the belly of the
machine, and then
they get spat out of the
phallic elephant tusk,
and they go out into the
community where the coins get
spread around for
everyone to share.
So she completely grasped
the idea of redistribution
and why she thought
it was important.
And she thought it
was a good idea.
Kids like sharing.
Most kids, at least.
So I spotted this not
long ago on the wall
of my daughter's hippie
Quaker school in Brooklyn.
I was impressed that they had
put it up in the first place.
But then, of course, I had
to get to the bottom of it.
And being a professional busy
body, I took a picture of it,
and I sent it to
the kids' parents.
And I said, what's
going on here?
And they said, we don't know.
So I just left it at that.
But then a week
or two later, they
wrote me back and they said,
Ron, we figured it out.
We were cleaning up the books on
the boys' floor in his bedroom.
This boy was in kindergarten
at the time, I think,
so they were just
learning to write.
And they said we figured
out where this came from,
because he was reading a book
about-- can anybody guess what
it was about?
He was reading a book
about the Boston Tea Party.
So his problem
wasn't with taxes.
His problem wasn't
with higher taxes.
He just didn't want to pay
higher taxes to the British.
So it turns out that he, too,
was hard wired for sharing.
So you can have these
conversations with your kids.
This is a conversation that
we had with our daughter
about how we divide
our charitable giving.
We said, all right,
Talia-- we're going
to put 100 beans on the table.
Each one represents $1.
And for every $100 we give away,
this is how we divide it up.
So $17 goes to curing
river blindness, which
is a devastating
disease, and there
are charities that can literally
save a life for every $122
that you give.
So we think it's
important to save lives.
We do that.
We give money to the
educational institutions
that's supported me with
scholarship money when
I didn't have enough.
Our mother is 35-year
and counting survivor
of premenopausal breast cancer.
We support breast
cancer organizations.
On my wife's side, there's a
bunch of Holocaust survivors,
so we keep tabs on the
elderly Jews in our community,
and we give money to the
American Jewish World Service,
and Public Radio, and
homeless children,
and many other things.
So we said to our daughter,
does this look OK to you?
Are there any piles
that are missing?
And if so, what do you
think we should do about it?
So we started on this with
her when she was eight.
But you can have this
conversation with 12-year-olds.
You should have it
with 16-year-olds.
It just gets more and
more complex and nuanced.
And she looked at
it, and she said,
I think it's great
that we help students
at schools who are like
Daddy, who didn't have enough,
and now, because of
the money that we give,
they can go to school the
same way that Daddy did.
But the thing that I
love doing the most
is going to summer camp,
going to sleep away camp,
and I'd like to give money
for a scholarship for people
who don't have enough
money to go there.
So that had not occurred to us.
We didn't even know if
such a thing existed.
But we checked it out,
and sure enough, they
did have a scholarship fund.
So we gave her three beans.
We said, you can move the
beans from any pile you want.
You decide where you think we
should take the beans from.
Because it means a trade-off.
It means that organization
won't get as much,
but the kids who want
to go to your camp will.
And so you have to decide
where they come from.
And so she chose, and
we added three beans
to the Eisner Scholarship Fund.
And now each and
every year, we're
going to give her a
couple more beans.
So that as she gets
older and smarter,
is able to think about these
things in a more nuanced way,
she will be able to have ever
more influence on our family's
giving.
Because why shouldn't she?
She's part of the family, too.
So it's only a short step
from generosity to gratitude.
If you're lucky enough to be
able to throw the rope back
for others, it means that
you are truly fortunate,
and it's good to remind
yourself of that once in awhile.
If you are a person of
faith or a family of faith,
maybe you say grace each night.
Or maybe the idea of grace
makes you feel uncomfortable.
That's fine.
There are plenty of forms of
godless grace that you can say,
family gratitude rituals
that you can develop.
They don't feel
like grace at all.
Toasting is my favorite one.
Kids love to give toast.
They love the noise, they love
the liquid sloshing around,
they love the rowdiness.
And there are really
no rules to toasting.
The only rule is that
everybody gets a turn
to raise their glass to
someone or something awesome
from that day.
And even if you've had
the worst possible day,
there's almost always
something awesome.
And once you start doing
this daily gratitude ritual,
whether it's you alone as an
adult, which I encourage--
it's made me a happier
person, because I do it--
or as a family, whenever
you manage to sit down,
it helps to take at least
some of the attention
away from the things that you
want, or that you yearn for,
that you can't have, or
that you don't have yet,
and brings the
focus really where
it belongs-- on the
things that you already
have, on the luck,
and the good fortune,
and the great things
about you and your family
and your community
and the people in it.
I encourage you to try it.
It's powerful stuff.
So people often worry or wonder
when I give these talks about
kids, and working, and
how much they should work,
and whether we're not teaching
them a work ethic if we're not
paying them for their allowance.
I actually think kids
should work plenty.
Work has gone out of style
in the United States.
The percentage of
teenagers who are working
has gone down like 50% in
just the last 15 years.
There are a bunch
of reasons for this.
All of the labor laws that we
have that avoid that situation
are perfectly appropriate.
And there are other
macroeconomic reasons
why this has happened.
But mostly, I think it's
because of the college
admissions industrial complex.
There's a sense out there that
college admissions officers
devalue work, and
that they care more
about the time you spent
in the after school coding
club, or your time
on the soccer team,
or your time staring
for the school play.
It's actually not true.
I've reported it out with the
college admissions officers.
They only wish more kids
would do more paid work,
and would write passionately
about it in their essays.
Because all they
see is drama club
and coding club and
student athletes now,
and they are bored to tears by
all these overly packaged kids.
Work, it turns out, is something
that kids are hard-wired to do.
They yearn to
display confidence.
Every time I turned
around in the early stages
of my reporting, I was hearing
from families, particularly
suburban families,
where kids were
involved in all sorts of
intense recycling rituals.
The kids just really wanted
to gather the cans and bottles
and be responsible
for turning them in
and get the money
that way, because that
was something they could do.
It was right in front of them.
It was a helpful task
around the house,
and they could make money at it.
I was so interested in
this and fascinated by it
that I followed the Clark
family to the scrap yard one day
in downtown San
Jose, California.
And these girls walk right in.
They know all the
cashiers by name.
And they go to the clear bottle
collection container, and then
the green bottle, and
then the brown bottle,
and then the aluminum cans,
and then the plastic bottles,
and they stop everywhere
along the way.
Literally glass shards flying.
There's so much
noise in this place
that they give you ear plugs.
And the girls just
walk through, and then
they walk out with $75 each,
and they go to the credit union.
Kids like doing this stuff.
And they're capable of a lot.
I spent a bunch time
with farm families
just to remind myself of
what five-year-olds can do.
We tend not to think
much of five-year-olds.
But in fact,
five-year-old Zebadiah,
the youngest of eight boys on
a dairy farm in Northern Utah--
1,800 head of cattle--
Zebadiah starts
working at the age of five
when they pick them up,
and they put him on the
tractor, and he drives it.
They put it in gear.
Zeb's job is to make sure
the tractor stays straight.
And the seven-year-old
and the nine-year-old
follow behind him, and
they take the bottles,
and they put them
in the calf pen
so the calf have milk to drink.
And the bottles have been
filled by the 11-year-old
and the 13-year-old
brother with the milk
that the 15-year-old and
the 17-year-old brother
got from the milk machines that
they hooked up to the cows.
And this all gets
done between 5:00
in the morning and
7:00 in the morning
before the boys go to
school, and then it
gets done again after
school, and then
it gets done again
on the weekends.
They take Sundays off.
Five-year-olds can do a lot.
Every five-year-old in the
Smith family gets a gun.
The gun is part of their job.
They know how to use it.
They know how to use it safely.
Not once did Zeb point
the weapon at me.
Zeb's job is to
scare the birds away.
The birds are a nuisance.
They spread disease.
They harass the cows.
And the birds now
know when crew cut
Zeb raises his weapon that
it is time to scatter.
And that is Zeb's job.
We're in a technology company.
I wanted to talk just for
a minute or two about this.
If you're going to give
your kid a smartphone,
definitely give them
your version one iPhone
with a wireless carrier
that doesn't exist anymore.
But seriously, smartphones
for kids, they are a want.
They are not a need.
Kids need voice service.
They need texting
ability, because it's
how people communicate.
I do not think internet
access on the go
with a data plan is
something that children need.
And so if they want
it, that's great,
but they should pay
for it themselves.
Let them make trade-offs.
Let them decide just
how much it's worth,
or whether they're
probably going
to be just fine
with whatever access
they have on their
school machines
and whatever access they
have on your home machines.
So for the kids who do have
cell phones in Manhattan,
I've heard from all
sorts of parents--
this is true in
the Bay Area, too,
and also in LA--
so many parents who
have said, if I see
another Instagram
photo of a child
on a private jet,
I'm going to throw the phone
off the Empire State Building.
This happens.
Instagram I think, is an
engine of envy for these kids.
They don't realize that
everybody-- or most people,
at least-- are
using social media
to put their best
selves forward,
that it's a catalog of awesome.
Look at my awesome family,
and my awesome turkey,
and my awesome vacation, and
me having an awesome time
at a party that you're not
invited to with the friends
that you thought were
your close friends.
And these kids are
literally supposed
to press their noses up
against the iPad glass
and like it, hit the
thumbs up button.
I think this is way more
pernicious than any form
of commercial television,
and it's something
worth keeping a close eye on.
Yet another reason not
to let them walk around
with social media access.
And that's not to say
that we should ban it.
But we should look
over the shoulder
when they're using
it the same way
that we would if they
were watching TV.
I want to talk for just a
brief minute about college.
One of the biggest reasons I
did this book in the first place
was because we had gotten
to a point in America
without anyone ever
really acknowledging it
where 16 and 17 and 18-year-olds
are making six figure
decisions, sometimes
completely on their own,
often with the help of
parents who don't really
understand the size
and the numbers
and aren't doing the math.
If you're not getting any
financial aid-- and who
knows when the kids are younger
whether you will or not,
so you have to plan for
this-- to go to Binghamton
or Stonybrook or
New Paltz now-- it's
$100,000 to walk in the door,
to pay for room and board,
to pay for four or five years.
$100,000 for most flagship
state universities.
If your kid is going to go to
some kind of private college
and you don't know about
the financial aid situation,
or if they'll get this
merit aid, which is really
just a form of
discounting, that's
going to be $250,000 in
today's dollars per child.
Let alone for those of us who
have a couple little people,
or little people on the way,
who may be looking at half
a million dollars per child.
It's an incredible
amount of money.
The kids need to be ready.
And one of the biggest
problems with what's
going on with college
today is that we literally
have no data on which to make
our purchasing decisions.
It's the most important
decision, arguably,
of these kids' entire lives.
They're making it
at 16 or 17, and we
have no data on salary
outcomes and choice of majors.
We have no data on what
they are actually learning
and how much smarter
they've gotten,
how much bigger their brains
have gotten in four years.
We have no data on how
they've develop personally
in terms of just fine
tuning their personality,
whether they're
happier, whether they're
more capable of
general problem solving
in their personal lives.
We have no data on
who they're meeting,
on the quality of
the relationships,
on the networking opportunities,
on whether these are ties
that they are forming as
undergraduates that bind.
We know absolutely nothing.
It is a national disgrace
that our educational system
costs people 10x more than
the next cheapest educational
higher educational systems
in the developed world.
It's insane.
And yet, this is the system
that we have inherited.
This is the system that we
are preparing our kids for.
They need to be ready to figure
out how to reckon with it,
how to begin to come to terms
with not just the value,
but their values as they
relate to assessing the value.
Because the real problem with
the way these big decisions
are made now is that so many
of them are based on snobbery.
People come to the
conclusion that private
is better than
public, or that small
is better than big,
or that more expensive
has to be better than less
expensive, that the dorms
with the lazy river
rafts, outdoor pools--
this actually goes on
in many universities,
and not just the most expensive
ones-- that those have
to be better than the ones
that don't have the swimming
pools and the new dorms.
And this is how many kids
are making the decision now.
It's the wrong way
to make the decision.
It's the wrong way to make
a really big decision.
But it's understandable.
Because at the end
of the day, so much
of these money decisions
are tied up in emotions.
And we're used to talking
to kids about feelings,
about honoring their feelings,
about soothing their hurt
feelings, talking to them
about their raw, embarrassing
emotions.
And that, we've gotten good at.
We honor their feelings.
We pay close attention to them.
To my mind, their
questions about money
are just as important.
And one of keys to
raising decent kids
and to making sure they're happy
is understanding that equation
and honoring their
curiosity about money just
as much as we honor their
raw, important emotions, too.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
As you may have guessed,
I have other acts
of long form journalism I
intend to commit in this area.
If you sign up here,
you'll hear from me
every so often about some of
the things that I'm doing.
And I'll be asking
for help, too,
as I begin to gather some
string on further projects.
So if you want to sign
up, I'd be grateful.
All I need is your first
name and your email address,
and I won't bug you more
than every month or two.
And I'm happy to
answer any questions
or stick around and sign
books or whatever, although I
know some of you have to go.
So go if you need to.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: How
likely do you think
it is that the
college system will
exist in its current
form in about 15 years?
RON LIEBER: I think
it's extremely likely,
because snobbery.
These brands are going
to continue to matter,
and I think they're
going to continue
to matter to a lot of people.
And parents who,
for better or worse,
aspire to great
things for their kids
are just not to
be able to resist.
A, the data that just shows that
people who go to college out
earn people who don't--
no matter where they go--
out earn people who don't buy
like zillions of dollars over
their lifetime.
The numbers are
just off the charts.
So kids will keep going.
And parents who want to wear
the better-than-new sweatshirt
and put the sticker
on their car are
going to have a really hard
time tacking against that
to send their kid
a MOOC or to have
them do a certificate
for this trade
or that trade or that skill.
Even if it's taking
the 18-year-old who's
obsessed with developing
apps and putting them
straight into a hardcore coding
class for 12 or 18 months.
For some kids, that may be,
in fact, the best thing.
But it takes a lot of guts
to do something really,
really different.
18 years ago or
something, I wrote a book
about taking gap
years from college
and how that is so
clearly a better way
to approach higher education,
i.e., starting at 19 and not
at 18 when you're still trying
to fine tune your personality
and you're out of the
house for the first time.
And even to this day,
it's not mainstream,
even though that's how the
rest of the developed world
does things.
Kids don't go to college at 18.
They do military
service, or they
take some sort of a gap year.
It still hasn't
hit the mainstream.
So even if we do come
up with a better way
to do this, a
cheaper way, I just
think it's going to take a
long time for it to set in.
And I get that there are other
changes in the world, changes
that this company has
brought to the world that
have been way more quick than
what I'm predicting will happen
with higher education.
But I just don't see these
institutions crumbling anytime
soon, particularly the
top 50 or 100 or 150
that many parents just
can't help but aspire
to for their children.
And also, we should keep in mind
that the kids play a role here,
too.
They bat their eyes
at us and they say,
but this is what I really want.
And it's like, are
we really going
to, in this really
important moment,
deny them the thing that they
most want for their next four
years, even though we think they
may need something different?
It will be very,
very difficult, I
think, for many of us to say
no and do something else.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I really love the idea of
engaging honestly and directly
with kids about the
numbers that are actually
involved in terms of the
family salaries and the family
expenses.
But how do you talk to kids
about that in a truthful way
without having to be overwhelmed
by the difference in magnitude
between the numbers that are
going on in a family level
and what's going on at their
individual allowance or savings
level?
Why should they have
to sweat and slave
to put away $10, $20 to buy this
toy when Mommy and Daddy are
making so much more
money and spending
so much money on vacations.
Oh, this is how much it costs
for us to go to Florida.
That's silly.
Why don't we just tack a
tiny little bit more on,
and we can all get Barbies.
RON LIEBER: Much
depends on what you
want to make them
responsible for and when
you want to introduce
them to those big numbers.
So I believe in doing
this really gradually.
And I do think you
should be transparent,
but I don't think you
should be transparent
until they are ready,
until they have the math
skills, until they have
the context, until they
have the experience of
doing it themselves.
AUDIENCE: So until they're
making those kind of salaries
you're saying?
RON LIEBER: No.
Until they're able to reckon
with numbers that large.
So if you think about
it on a continuum--
you start at age six
or seven, and you're
going along with the allowance,
and it's $5, $6, $8 a week.
Maybe you increase it over time.
Maybe the time they're
9 or 10 and they've
been doing it for a while,
you sit down with them
and say, you know what?
A, we're not going
to pay for anything
you want anymore, only at the
holidays and on your birthday.
And anything you want, you're
going to have to pay for.
And we're going to increase
your allowance by 100%.
But you're only increasing
it to the point where
they can get a few of
the things that they want
and not so much that
they don't have to make
a lot of really hard choices.
And then, slowly,
you introduce them
to bigger numbers-- the
grocery bill, maybe the rent,
or the mortgage, all
the household expenses.
In the meantime in the
background, they're in school,
and they're now using four-
and five- and six-digit numbers
in math class.
So they're learning
more about that.
They're getting used
to the bigger numbers.
And you're saying
to them, look, this
is part of our family's reality.
There are these
three-digit numbers
and these four-digit checks,
or electronic payments that we
have to make each month.
And so you may
think that we have
a lot, because there are
all these big numbers
floating around.
But in fact, this is what
we need to spend in order
to have the life that we have.
And it turns out that
there's not a lot left over
at the end of the month.
And we're going to
tell you what that is.
But first, you need
to understand--
before we get to
the bigger numbers,
you need to understand
what we're spending.
And that takes years for
them to learn all that.
Because if you did it all at
once, they would be bored.
So you look for your moments.
You look for your openings.
You could spend a year
just walking the aisles
at Whole Foods or Fairway.
Every single stop
in the grocery aisle
is an intense lesson
in wants and needs.
You've got environmental impact,
and you've got nutrition,
and you've got social
responsibility,
and you've got whatever
your budget is,
and maybe you've
got some coupons.
All this stuff-- each
of those decisions
is its own kind of microcosm
of awesome trade-offs.
So you could spend a whole year
in the grocery store alone.
So then eventually,
13 or 14, by then,
they've probably googled you.
They've googled your address.
Maybe they've gone
to salary.com.
Seriously, there are kids
who do this at 10 or 11.
They've put software developer,
senior software developer,
lead software developer-- they
look at your business card,
they take that term, they
put it into salary.com,
and they kind of figure it out.
AUDIENCE: So kind of
like the sex talk--
wait until they googled it
already, and you can avoid it.
RON LIEBER: Well, that's right.
They're figuring this out.
They're getting the Zillow
estimate on your apartment.
So they're starting to know.
So at that point,
you're like, OK, look,
we really do want to share
this information with you.
In fact, you need it.
It's important for you to
know what it is that we have
and what it is that we make
that allows us to live and do
wherever we live
and whatever we do.
But we're not going
to give it to you
yet, because you have to
prove that you can keep it
to yourself.
And we're going to check to
make sure that you are treating
your friends'
information privately,
and we're going to watch
you carefully to see
if you're getting
conflicts there.
We're going to watch
with your siblings
if you have them to see if
you're reading their diaries
or tattling on them
when they're not
doing something that's dangerous
or worth tattling about.
We're going to
keep an eye on how
you deal with other
information, private information
that the family gives you.
And then we're going
to sit you down
and say, OK, we're going
to tell you all of it now.
You're 16, you're 17.
10 years have gone by.
You are ready.
But if you tell anyone,
it will be a sign
that we shouldn't trust you,
because you're not as mature
as we thought you were.
So this is a test.
And by the way, if
you do tell people,
it's not really going to
matter so much to them.
Because maybe they
have a little more,
and maybe they
have a little less.
But they're just not going
to be all that interested.
And if it turns that you're
like the zillionaire next door,
and nobody knows it, and
you tell your kids that
and they blab about
that, then they're
going to sound like jerks,
because their bragging.
So no kid wants to
flunk the jerk test.
No kid wants to flunk
the maturity test.
And the kid wants to
use all this information
in an appropriate way by
the time they're that old.
And they want your respect.
And so by then,
and only then, are
they ready to get all
of that information.
AUDIENCE: And that helps lead
into the picking a college
major conversation as well.
If you want to have
these same things,
you need to make long-term
financial planning decisions.
RON LIEBER: Yeah.
Because most parents
think, well, gosh, they
worry, how on Earth
is my kid going
to be able to
reproduce what I've
been able to create for them?
Because I didn't have a big
pile of student loan debt,
and the price of
college was different,
and I was lucky enough
to get hired at Google
and work here or go
work for a startup
before or after or in
between or whatever.
But it turns out that there
are all sorts of kids who don't
want what their parents have.
Maybe they want to be artists,
or public school teachers,
or start a small business that
doesn't involve technology.
Maybe they want to be
artisans or mechanics.
Or who knows?
And so they may well
say to themselves,
OK, well, if it took $220,000
in household income for us
to have 2 and 1/2 a bedroom,
one bath apartment a mile
from the Googleplex in New York,
maybe I can get by on $50,000
a year if I lived in Bushwick.
And I'll make that decision.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
PRESENTER: And just
time for one more
question, and then
we'll stick around.
RON LIEBER: OK.
I'm happy to hang
around, though,
if you want to do a one-on-one.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks.
This has been hugely valuable.
RON LIEBER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering--
in our household,
we have two little kids.
The older one is 4
and 1/2, so we're
starting to teach the values
of wants versus needs, mostly
around the topic of
tutus at this point.
But the issue is the influx
of stuff from family members
outside of our immediate family.
And we're trying to teach
that goods are exhaustible.
That if you finish your
book of 1,000 stickers,
that's the end of the book.
But then we get a shipment from
the grandparents and the aunts,
and et cetera.
So how do you manage
those factors outside
of your control?
RON LIEBER: Sure.
So on a very basic
level, you control access
to the box cutter.
So when the packages come,
you can open them out of view.
You can open them after bedtime.
You can put them away
for as long as you want.
If the grandparents give you a
problem with that, well, tough.
Because you're in charge.
Now, the bigger issue
with grandparents
is that they're a
menace generally.
They exist to subvert every
last one of our rules.
My brother and I happen
to share a mother who
sent a black leather
miniskirt to our daughter
when she was five.
That went back to the store.
So they love pushing
the boundaries.
They take joy in it, in fact.
It gives them glee.
And so look, I would say-- I
literally had a sample chapter
title in my book proposal that
said grandparents are a menace.
But in fact, if they're not a
part of your day-to-day life
or your week-to-week
life, if they're not
your primary caregiver
when you're not around,
say, or they don't
live with you,
then I think you can
let some of that go.
Although by all
means, parcel out
the packages to whenever the
stickers are about to be gone,
or they have been gone
for a little while.
It's good that kids
love their grandparents,
that they want to spend
time with the grandparents
so that we can have
time to ourselves.
But you're also asking
a bigger question
there, which is that if you're
lucky enough to have more
than you need, you
can, in fact, replenish
the stuff as it goes away, and
they need not want or yearn.
But you should make them anyway.
Because patience is good.
Yearning is good.
You can even set a
benchmark for yourself.
I talk about this in
the book a little bit.
Some parents say, OK,
well, I think on average,
I want my kid to be in the
30th percentile of stuff,
or I want for every 10 kids
that my child is closest
to, their 10 closest friends,
I always want my child to be,
on average, the seventh kid
to get whatever the kids are
excited about-- so
the seventh Rainbow
Loo, set, the seventh
set of Hunter boots,
the seventh a Death
Star LEGO, whatever.
Because then they wait.
And it's good for them to wait.
And quite often, by the
time the fourth or the fifth
or the sixth kid has
gotten something, the first
and the second and the third
kid are bored with that thing
and are onto something
else, and your kid
doesn't even need to get it.
But again, it's good
for them to wait.
It's good for them to save.
It's good for them to pay
for things themselves.
And it requires some
resistance on your part,
but I think it's doable.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks.
RON LIEBER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]